[Applause]
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people showed
up in the nation's capital saturday
for the women's march on washington we
are done waiting
we are the ones we have been waiting for
let's get to work
a record number of women and minorities
won in closely watched races across the
country more than 150 women and girls
confronted nassar before his sentencing
this is what it looks like
when institutions create a culture where
a predator can flourish
unafraid and unabated a judge just
sentenced former usa women's gymnastics
dr larry nassar
it looks like a courtroom full of
survivors who carry deep
wounds women and girls who have banded
together to fight for themselves because
no one
else would do it we are here on this
stage to present an
image for the world to see a portrait
of survival
an untold number of women posted me too
and revealed
their deeply intimate experiences of
abuse their stories flooded social media
and painted a picture of just
how many people endure sexual abuse and
harassment every day
[Applause]
what we represent by gathering and
marching in the streets is a reminder
a living grieving reminder that we are
human beings not hashtags
[Applause]
brooke baldwin joins us now to discuss
brooke i think that piece
really set up your book and the premise
of your book very nicely so good
yeah very well done go us thanks but
really good to have you here but you say
this
i didn't do i didn't do the piece other
people did i think it was
very well done but you say this a
gathering of women does not a huddle
make
so what makes a huddle yeah a huddle is
a place it's every it's every image
we just saw in that beautifully produced
piece it's a place where women come
together and are
empowered by the mere fact of their
coexistence it can be productive right
it can lead to change it's a space where
women
lean on one another to to thrive to
survive get amazing things done
but it can also gail just be a quiet
space where women come together and just
bear witness for one another
it can be the women who who you pray
with who you sweat with
the moms who you lean on the co-workers
who you
share vital information to be able to to
to rise through the ranks at work
that is a huddle you know you write
about yourself
growing up as a upper middle class white
girl your words
rarely huddled for anything that didn't
involve sequins or tap shoes
i thought that painted the picture very
well a little bit about your upbringing
so
when did you realize brooke that you
needed a huddle and that other women can
certainly benefit from a huddle
yes i mean certainly blessed wonderful
parents great childhood surrounded by
lots of little girls and tap shoes and
gymnastics and soccer and you name it i
was full of
girl huddles but then coming through uh
ultimately graduating from the
university of north carolina jumping
into
journalism fulfilling my dream of one
day maybe being it you know cnn when
you're from atlanta you drink coca-cola
you root for the braves and you want to
work at cnn and i have fulfilled that
dream
but all the while you know in my 20s and
early 30s
it's been a very lonely climb and i was
huddleless
for over a decade i had some singular
extraordinary girlfriends but gail i
realized honestly after
it was the this two two day window we
talked about this the other night when
you helped me launch my book and it
really got me thinking that the the two
days between being embedded in the trump
motorcade
on inauguration day in january of 2017
and then the very next day
back on the clock for cnn and covering
the women's march and being surrounded
by half a million women that was my aha
moment
of a something special is happening with
collectives of women in this country
like look at these pictures
yeah you said it was life-changing how
many women would show up
it was life-changing for me it was
because i realized that i wanted to be
very intentional about dedicating this
next chapter of my life to covering
collectives of women number one and
number two gail i stood there and i was
like
okay reporter had off um would i have
had a huddle
to share a tank of gas or to stand in
those really long port-a-potty lines
with and the answer was no
and so i realized through the process of
osmosis and the privilege i had of
interviewing these various huddles of
women for my book
that a i needed to activate a huddle and
b i wanted to inspire other women to do
the same
brooke it's anthony you announced you're
leaving cnn after
13 years was was this part of what was
behind that and and what's your next
chapter
um first of all can i just i am such a
fan of yours and have been watching you
for many many years
such a such a fan anthony mason you stop
this now answer my questions
i yes it's cnn has been my home
cnn the people at cnn you all know you
know being at cbs and like you're
surrounded by your family i've been
surrounded by my family for 13 years you
know it started when i basically put my
name outside of a temporary office with
a post-it with my name scribbled on it
until i
created space for myself and they hired
me and i became this anchor at 31
but it's time you know i remember my dad
saying to me once upon a time brooke
when you get somewhere and you're really
comfortable and i have been comfortable
and privileged and had this
you know extraordinary platform it's
time to move on and anthony i think to
answer your question
with regard to the book yeah how could i
not after spending
two years of my life after this
life-changing moment at the the women's
march of the trump inauguration
and sharing space with these women
between you know meeting ava duvernay
gail king um the ladies behind reese
witherspoon sarah
hardin at hello sunshine to the the
women behind mom's demand action
shannon watts congresswoman lisa mcbath
to those women on capitol hill like
and megan or pino i could keep keep
going on they're all in my book stacey
abrams
i cannot hold space with them
and not be the bravest version of myself
possible and in order to do that anthony
mason i have to take what i've been
referring to is this back backflip off
the high dive and leave cnn
it's very scary but it's exciting yeah i
have a feeling when she says she doesn't
know her next chapter number one i don't
believe you brooke baldwin so i can't
wait to see what that is
but you also say this about huddling a
huddle can be small it could be big
you may love your work but work doesn't
love you back so it's good
it's good to have a huddle that you can
count on at all times for all things
really good to see you brooke yeah
thank you so much and thank you for
being in my huddle gal king for for all
of these years and inspiring me some
love
i like being in your huddle brook
baldwin we thank you huddle is on sale
now wherever you like to buy
your books it is there all right